we're starting the top of the news with
some bottoms good housekeeping reports
that there's a 30
pair of butt sculpting leggings that
claim to
plump your rump see some leggings are
all the rage on tick tock
number one on amazon's leggings for
women
and do they really yum your bum will
textile experts say
yes the secret is in the ruching
which is a special curved seam on the
back that makes your butt look curvier
ally i saw you working out on instagram
are you ready to juice that caboose or
what
i am not a girl who believes in all
those
uh smoke and mirrors my feeling is
this is what i got you know what i mean
i've been married for 100 years
i'm not going to make any secrets these
are real this is real nothing's padded
good night gracie you know lee harris
who is the
star brilliant stylist um i mean we're
just it's we're such good friends we've
worked together for 20 years
he would give anything to get me in a
pair of spanx that's all he ever wants
to do is squeeze me
into some tidy shape-shifting
forming things and i won't do it that
poorly i'm sorry but i just can't i get
it every job i've ever had
i get four pairs of spanx in my trailer
and
big padded bras yeah and i go all right
i'm not enough
apparently lee would pour me into a tube
of toothpaste and reshape me if he could
so you're a no to these two these
leggings i i can't breathe
well i don't know the leggings i i'm i'm
intrigued but for me it's about the fit
and the feel i don't care i i don't i
can't
try to look a certain way and be
uncomfortable about it i
completely agree okay all right so
next drew people show their love in
mysterious ways
and now glamour reports brooklyn beckham
and his fiancee actress nicola peltz
have said
i love you by swapping teeth
nicola had their wisdom teeth plated in
gold
and now they're wearing them on
necklaces hmm have you ever
traded teeth with a lover no but i it
just harkens back to that angelina jo
billy bob but the blood the vials of
blood on the red carpet
i remember that was a real story yeah i
never
i've never traded parts but i
was proposed to once not by george
stephanopoulos
um by a boyfriend who said was very
nervous that he had a
polyp and he said will you check it out
and i was like
i'm an uptight wasp i don't want to
check anything and he laid down on a
towel
and there was an engagement ring
sticking out of his butt
[Applause]
i said yes and then i said is there a
necklace to go with this ring
but that was like as far as i got to
sort of
swapping stuff yeah yeah
i once um i dated an artist fabrizio
moretti for almost six years i love him
so much we're still friends
obviously and um i he's an artist so he
would make me these like ex
like a zoetrope machines and like he was
so fantastic and so i went to a doctor
and got an x-ray of my heart
and then put it on a light board so it
was a piece of art that's romantic
that's not icky like my story
no but it's like just give me funny
that's
that's my motto yeah yeah so when george
proposed very romantically on an island
in greece i was like no
okay well then this story is so perfect
because i do want to know your thoughts
on this
good sleep has been hard to come by this
year and many sleep deprived
people who are coupled up are trying
something we call
a sleep divorce huffpost reports that
this is when you and your partner agree
to sleep in separate rooms to get a
better night's rest and experts say this
is a totally healthy solution
and it shouldn't have a stigma attached
because better sleep means better moods
and clearer communication the next day
and it can actually
help your marriage alley thoughts well
i have been married for 20 years and my
husband
gets up at 2 30 in the morning to gma
and i
sleep with him every night i go to bed
with him at 8 30
because i want to stay married because
he leaves at 2 30.
but i have a lot of friends that because
of snoring issues or tossing issues
i don't want to get him in trouble but
the man that
miked me said that he flips around a lot
so
he and his significant other are
separate and it seems to work out
really really well so i i have no
problem with it
i don't either i'm just like you know
what it
who said these are the rules exactly
like maybe you do you and you do what's
best for yourself
if i want to sleep with other people i
should be oh i'm sorry
that's not what we're talking about
right no but i i do think that if there
are
issues with getting enough sleep sleep
is the most important thing
so fine go go sleep in the guest room
you can and by the way
you can have sex in other rooms during
other times so
you know what my motto is ally live man
yeah sleep in separate bedrooms do it
yes
sick of everyone judging each other me
too your story
all right drew um so you are
a beauty brand ceo and i love your stuff
and you love cute stuff so fasten your
seat belts for this
pop sugar reports makeup company hip dot
has teamed up with peeps and their peep
inspired
shades for your peepers just in time for
easter and check out these little
squishy
chick sponges how cute are these
no they're they're painful it's so cute
they're so cute and by the way
i have teenage girls that just gouge my
makeup
yes and to give to give them these
instead of
eggs that are filled with caramel which
i end up eating is
a better basket treat i think for easter
ally you're absolutely right i've
already been stressing
about the like easter egg hunt and too
much chocolate
because you know if couples are worried
about sleeping put
children on tons of chocolate and see
where that goes
yes oh hi easter bunny
how are you that is one
delicious bunny bunny's actually and
look at these peep colors
i know how fun would it be have like a
pink poppy or blue
shadow people go gaga for this because
it's
fun it's imaginative people need to have
more fun and
i think co-lab is the perfect way to do
it um i think that
flower beauty should team up with the
candy company too
well i think you just gave me the best
idea which is i'm gonna plant a bunch of
these on the easter egg hunt well
exactly or even place them in your
easter egg basket
my girls will go crazy over this and i'm
taking these home i don't care who they
belong to
do it do it do it ally i love getting to
do this with you i love getting a jew
with you please let it be the second of
so many more times
let's see what the paycheck says and
maybe i will just
you are my kind of woman i'll sleep with
you or a part whatever you want
okay all right ally's podcast go ask ali
is streaming now on iheartradio
or wherever you get your podcast